[Music]
time now for a final exam where we
mercilessly pit - noted news experts
against one another to find out who's
actually been paying attention to the
news joining us tonight
town hall editor Katie Pavlich she's our
defending champion this week her
challenger is Fox correspondent and
frequent final exam contestant Peter
Doocy welcome to you both thank you you
both know the rules but I'm gonna repeat
them just in case you've forgotten hands
on buzzers I ask the questions the first
one to buzz in gets to answer the
question you have to wait until I finish
asking in order to answer every correct
answer is worth a point if you get it
wrong you lose a point best of five wins
you've been here before are you ready
ready are you ready I don't know how
much more time could I possibly get we
roll mercilessly for a question one
doctors say they are working overtime to
treat kitchen injuries people it turns
out are accidentally cutting themselves
when slicing a certain fruit this has
gotten so bad what is the fruit because
that was the question we're gonna let it
go Peter what's the fruit avocado final
answer
I just hot Oh finally I don't answer we
just let's go to the tape I stabbed
myself in the pant with a knife I was
trying to open up an avocado apparently
there is a syndrome called avocado hands
it's real we get this all the time I'm
Hakata you were correct and our judges
have just said it sounded as if I had
finished asking the question so it's
basically my fault they're saying so you
get the point Peter Doocy
and all those years of watching the view
every day for the full hour the downside
is you lost 30 IQ points okay question
to a daredevil animal just capture the
attention of the world by scaling a
20-story building in the state of
Minnesota the animal defy the odds I
made it all the way to the roof of the
building without falling which
four-legged nocturnal mammal was it
oh all right what animal was it a
raccoon a raccoon says Katie go to the
tape wasn't a raccoon a daring raccoon
scaling and off the tower in st. Paul
Minnesota a wildlife drama unfolding in
the some 20 stories in the air it was a
record really one of the most impressive
and underrated animals go you guys are
decisive BAM
they took over right freshservice
building one so it's crazy there's
they're such great animals and they
don't get the credit they deserve
question three if you're sick of
potholes one pizza chain has you covered
there now traveling the country fixing
roads the government won't fix in order
to make sure your pizza delivery goes
smoothly which chain is doing this
Domino's Peter Doocy Domino's is it
Domino's roll tape please Pizza one
pothole at a time okay Wow three
questions at three decisive correct
answers nice job it is now two to one
Peter Doocy over KT but things change
fast in this game as you know as we go
into question for this one is a
multiple-choice question about the
summit that we all just watch between
the presidents and the leader of North
Korea Kim jong-un Kim traveled to the
summit in Singapore with a very unusual
item and I didn't he refused to be
without was it a a king sized bed be a
portable toilet also known as a porta
potty or see a pet peacock porta potti
haiti porta potti this is Katie was it a
porta potty to the tape we go Gordon
reports North Korean leader Kim jong-un
brought his own toilet to Singapore for
his summit with President Trump to
prevent intelligence agencies from using
the sewer to get information on his
health
said intelligence agencies we're just
gonna go ahead and guess bad then so I
assumed as the peacock but that's even
weirder that's so impressive so now
we're moving into the final question the
decisive question number five its final
death overtime sudden death final
overtime whole time I'm not ready okay
here's the last question last week we
talked about I hop changing its name for
a limited time I hop will be called I
hob with a B what does the B stand for
International House of burgers okay
burgers burgers okay I don't believe you
for the record but we're gonna find out
if your right to the tape we go you know
what the B stands for no it's not bacon
no it's not breakfast no it's not
biryani
it's burgers you can get pancakes with
your burger at the same time so you
don't even have to choose you super
confused about brunch breakfast
ladies you won and you win the game but
before before you collect your prize
let me ask Peter you buzzed in almost
simultaneously sure's a little bit
faster than you did you know the answer
honestly I did know the answer as
burgers because I was very very
surprised after all the bill that I was
burgers yeah broccoli it's so out of the
category talk about getting outside your
Lane but whatever that's another show
congratulations two bills is the right
rate game Katie you are getting our
coveted Eric wimple mug that
commemorates the now famous appearance
of Eric went with Washington Post on our
show drink your coffee with pride in
that Peter Doocy it's great to see you
good game thanks doc thanks tucker